as restrictions ease businesses are
finding creative ways to engage
customers fashion show mall on the las
vegas strip has a new pop art exhibit
celebrating spring and bianca holman is
live there this morning to show us how
shoppers can
stop by for an instagram break bianca
tell us more
hey good morning sheri so yeah fashion
show mall definitely has those stairs in
front
instagramable posts they've probably
gone viral a few times but now they've
got this interactive
pop art experience inside the mall so
here take a look
this is like stepping inside of a big
cartoon i feel like it's so
fun and it's celebrating summertime and
to share more about
what all this entails i'm joined by
esther sarpong with the fashion show
mall so tell us about this interactive
experience
we are so excited to partner with pretty
dunn
to create this immersive instagramable
space on the second floor of fashion
show
right next to neiman marcus we invite
all guests to come in
and take that perfect instagramable
pictures it's completely complementary
and it's going to be a great experience
and so he's here he woke up early for us
to show us just how he works and again
each little face is different why is it
so important to support our local
artists
as a partner of the local community we
are a pillar in the community we know
that artists
and art is all about expressing yourself
and that's what fashion show is about
you can shop you can dine and you can be
your authentic self so walking into this
space
you can take that perfect picture and
get to meet adam
our local artist he's here till tomorrow
between 11 to 8 p.m you can come and
just get in his head a little bit
understand why he's making this super
amazing room
and what is inspiring him to create
these pieces yeah
and also yeah tell us those dates so
he's going to be here again tomorrow
and then friday it'll be open to the
public right he's here tomorrow from 11
to 8 so come visit him it's completely
complimentary and then after that
come on in any day the mall is open
visit our website from all hours and
come in and take that perfect picture
yeah there's so much to look at here
we've got aliens we've got
sharks little chickens tacos each little
face is different
just loads of fun and it just really
makes you smile if you're looking for a
reason to smile
right now coming here to this experience
and fashion inside fashion show mall
is where you want to be so we're going
to send it back to you guys in the
studio
and you know what coming up in the next
half hour we're actually going to talk
to the artist we're going to talk to
adam and see again how he comes up with
this because this is pretty incredible
you all
back to you guys in the studio thank you
bianca yeah it looks really cool
and we've i've seen a bunch of his work
at other places around town too really
distinctive stuff